hi I'm Salma Hayek hi I'm Roy bun and
I'm Tiffany Haddish and we're playing
Who's Who with BuzzFeed always looks
good even when we're like ok we're gonna
run over here she always has her makeup
on point no one really know we're all
[Music]
physically start with that she got
flaming red hair crazy teeth blue eyes
so already it's like she's nothing like
she always does it for promoting power
together and being a uni like yeah yeah
I do get P but in a different way not in
a defending of the women kinda way and
my you're not gonna screw us over it's
actually no dad no yeah you're gonna ask
who's most likely to take a nap in the
middle of the scene that would be me
[Laughter]
during a thing you forget between the
camera on the reverse I'm like and I'm
I'm hitting on my life all her life you
know what's mesmerized me was she was
really really overworked during this
film
amazingly overworked and yet she was
always on time and the couple of times
that she would snooze
she would like I would say something
she'd be like and then she respond
exactly on cue and then go back
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I think you know she she yeah Rosie
and most likely to nail it not mix one
word I'll take it
I'm gonna take that she's amazing you
know I want to go like hey honey you
need to take a nap you have to rest you
tell them the life is wrong who's doing
your makeup that is not be Amelie would
have been it's more her because I didn't
have to take the teeth of to eat it was
obligated yeah
good at that's great
someone gives the best advice and she's
like the matriarch you know so she's got
good advice but people you're the best
at it yeah you give the best advice
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I think Romi I would say either yeah she
goes she goes like these oh okay nice
thing to say but you actually do run an
empire yeah you're running you're about
to start running your empire it's in
already no idea what I got going on yeah
they say I can't keep secrets but yeah
[Music]
but that was because of the wig and the
teeth and your hair and makeup was like
that was a big production I like your
neck job yeah it was not easy but in
real life in real life we don't we're
not that - every letter it takes it
except if you're selling I don't think
you're worried 105 don't worry once you
get a little bit older you like I forget
about so make sure you check out
[Music]